foreign
[Music]
I decided to leave Harvard travel West
I hope to find a stronger purpose and
more meaning in my life
I do free
I would like to go
on a hunt
this will be one of the biggest Halls
anyone has ever seen
where are we going there
yourself
that's why I Fear God
you don't know
you'll see
[Music]
Miller there's no sense shooting more
weeded skin
metal skin than Fred or I'll shoot you
what are we still doing out here
I'm out here to hunt Buffalo
all that their hearts
and sell them
when we're done we'll sure have
something to show for him
let's just know
after everything you've seen out there
in the world
what are the Hunger Games for
are you
are you are you
coming to the truth
The Hunger Games are to punish the
district as tributes don't have a choice
Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles not survivors
free we're alive
smile it's why we have teeth
[Music]
that I was still of value
welcome to the Capitol you look like you
shouldn't be here I shouldn't but I'm
your Mentor a rebel
I don't care they want to protect people
and it's essential to accept what human
beings are
what it takes to control them
use that famous snow charm
you seem like a good man qualina snow I
have seen what war does to people
filled with the turf becoming prey see
how quickly we become predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction
engulfing the world
the monsters
[Music]
good luck with that poor little Songbird
where is she
it's a mystery and Mysteries have a way
of driving people
no let me ask you one final time what
are the Hunger Games for
Hanging Tree
it's the things we love most and destroy
us
what's heaven
[Music]
it's a peaceful place in the sky
are you going to heaven
no you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
so we're the same
we can't go to heaven because we're not
good
and I'm not a person
[Music]
they're coming to get me
I'm like a bodyguard I'm getting you out
of this
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
take care of her
I promise
[Music]
foreign
a girl was grabbed on 7th Street on
Saturday night right around the same
time that you got out of work can you
describe the man number one box like him
tell me everything and don't leave
anything out
[Music]
All Rise I don't want to see you become
damaged because it's not just for me the
prosecution calls Patricia Ann Shumway
I'm not the next girl
put this guy in jail for a long time the
jury has found you guilty as charged
low Earnest John Flynn can you get me
out of here I believe I can aren't you
gonna ask me if I'm guilty I'm far more
interested why you sign that confession
I know what you're trying to do a man's
as guilty as Sin the issue is whether
this defendant's confession should have
been allowed in evidence it was coercion
plain and simple there was not an
attorney present don't make him the face
of your Crusade what about Miranda's
victim
I really don't care objection your honor
the cases before us raise questions what
if they say he's not guilty the Supreme
Court might make us retry the whole
world wants nothing but to take from us
Miranda did not request counsel
therefore we reverse
they're being locked away is the only
thing that lets me sleep at night
all right
so hard time to keep your living this
over and over
she's worked so hard she's doing what's
right
Miranda our justice system has afforded
you every privilege every protection hey
this is a courtesy not extended to your
victim
is that it they all gone
your time guys okay come on everybody
here we go
100 Years of stories they get pink
100 Years of magic oh oh help and water
do you think all the villains will show
up not all
celebrate 100 Years of Disney with
Disney's new original short film Once
Upon a studio World broadcast Premiere
October 15th only on ABC so be careful
oh
four years ago I was basically
unemployed I Wanderer with no home
but now I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
my job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion
a billion every known species in the sea
and call this place home
that doesn't mean they don't like me I'm
gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds dear
I'm gonna murder his family
and burn his kingdom to Ash
he must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might go to help
us who
you look rough
good job little brother high five do not
call me brother
I cannot believe you let this happen
yeah well I hate this job true king
built Bridges right
who builds Bridges
Amanda is the for now
you're stronger than before
it's the black Trident
doing King atland's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
upon them all
he means to end the bloodline
[Music]
I don't know what lies ahead but we
can't leave our children in the world
without hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
[Music]
the Seven Kingdoms will follow
me
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
why does the zebra look the way it does
so embarrassing hey Focus says hold one
no it's different now
you've been on my mind recently yeah you
keep popping up in my dreams you don't
do anything you're just there
so this specific person the remarkable
nobody I'm also had that experience do
you have a picture
foreign
have you been dreaming about me have
I've been dreaming about you yeah
there's like a hundred messages somebody
wants to interview me I'm strange maybe
you should take a minute and think
before you do anything drastic
why me uh
I don't know I'm special I guess
I feel to go viral who's actually had a
dream about me
[Music]
he was killing me but I'm going to have
nightmares I wish I was the one people
were dreaming about me too yeah no it's
it's something how's he dealing with all
this we're not even the type of people
that like attention you know you think
other people are seeing you naked
I hope I'm behaving through your dreams
Oh no you're not so I'm finally cool huh
I didn't say that you hear that Janet
she's saying I'm a cool dad
I really feel like you're playing with
fire here exactly
I'm not actually doing anything to them
happy birthday
you know Fame can come with some less
desirable side effects you should be
prepared for that maybe we should cool
this thing off what what do you mean
it's embarrassing which part
I guess I'll uh I guess I'll see you in
my dreams
it's of course not
[Music]
thank you
that was class sorry that was my fault
are you okay you just had sack McLaren's
ball in your face what's his GPA
you have any books on Battletoads you
know video games are now the leading
cause of divorce Could you actually
order me a book on the moon really no
sarcasms frequently an attempt to
deflect one's ignorance so does it mean
to know it all oh wait you forgot your
credit card
oh my God
what's up the heck get a car now he's a
concussion and he thinks it on his
girlfriend thank God it's you oh no
alrighty he is dating Zoe oh no there's
no way he's either dead or he's dumbs me
honestly I'm not sure which is worse
make sure Zach takes it easy as symptoms
could get worse what do I do you don't
want him getting worse pretend to be the
other Zoe you've been dating two or
three weeks now right
this is Zach's cousin miles he's in grad
school at MIT oh my God a match for Zoe
I
think we're gonna Amnesia patient's
cousin we're all gonna go skiing in the
mountains this weekend you want to go
with us strip of land seven letters
oh how did you know that I've done
YouTube did you eat it stops okay we
shall
it's confusing I'm enjoying getting to
know you over again go take a swing up
lights
even Zach do you thinks you're a good
match like we are it's complicated
we need to tell him the truth you have
to go after what you want and be brave
oh my God you're just giving me wrong
com advice now no it's so fun
[Music]
so what did you do did you have fun what
didn't we do excuse me All PG-13 okay
[Music]
this evil is something different
where do you think we should come
wherever let's just enjoy every second
of getting the heck out of Ludlow
[Applause]
what the hell is that
[Music]
first place I learned about death was a
pet center
[Music]
the secret place
generation to generation
of things buried in that land
but come back
there's something else
[Applause]
can you hear them voices
I think something's wrong he needs time
to adjust
to build the pet cemetery
to protect them from evil
it's not Timmy
something's talking and driven
[Music]
hell what have you done
we have to find him
now stop this I held him the day he came
into this world and I'm gonna hold him
the day he goes out
believe me when I say
sometimes dead is better
[Music]
hello
hi so are you looking at me from the
street
[Music]
I'm assuming you're not with anyone
never see you with anyone
that's your mom and dad
yeah
they died
just before I was 12.
I'm trying to ride your bedtime at the
moment
how's it going
strangely
hi
this is real
does it feel real
our boys back home
our son look at you you were just a boy
now you're not
it was a long time ago
yeah I don't think that matters
[Music]
I've always felt like a stranger in my
own family
I'm always scared of something
always running away do you remember
sorry I never came in your room when you
were crying
it's funny it doesn't take much
to make you feel the way you felt back
there again
[Music]
I'd always fall in love
this is a new feeling you
and me together
[Music]
into the world
we are gonna make boy band history
tonight bro you're making baby Branch
nervous I feel like I'm gonna borrow and
pass out and pure pants all at once how
do you know
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
what's up my exquisitely chiseled rock
hard abs and I quit French we're out of
sync we've gone from Boys to Men and now
there's only one direction for us to go
the back streets bye see you later
Branch what oh hey are you all right
you're smiling and crying at the same
time it kind of looks like it's hurting
your face it does hurt my face
[Music]
I'm John Dory Branch's brother
former brother
[Music]
a brother is a friend who can never
leave you it's the strongest bond in the
world I would kill to have a sibling to
sing with check out your old outfits
puffy jacket hookah shell necklaces
denim tuxedo did you have frosted tips
you are so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic France my brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison there's only
one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner's
permit it was a Dolce McMahon face the
better question is are you a narc
who goes there we're here looking for
our brother
oh my gosh
my name is Villa it is so fantastic
amazing to see other trolls did you just
braid my hair you're welcome it looks so
good I love it is your dad King Pepe uh
yeah poppy I'm your sister my what whoa
hey man am I the only one without a long
lost sibling this is your second chance
with your brother's branch
maybe a smaller diaper this diaper was
any smaller I could
I could I know you think it's risky and
maybe it is but it'll be worth it
anyways always worth it you're all I
ever wanted
[Music]
you still got it looks like your
Band-Aids aren't behind you
I'd like to report a crime that hasn't
happened yet have you seen the movie
Back to the Future basically I'm living
that movie right now which is how I know
there's gonna be a murder tonight
hate time travel movies it never make
any sense
[Music]
this time of year is for us your friends
were murdered 35 years ago it's not 1987
anymore stay safe honey I love you
what the
excuse me what year is it 1987. oh my
God I know the 80s are almost over and I
haven't even tried Coke yet
I don't know
oh my God Mom
off and die Jesus mom
um Mamacita
for my birthday
this is a creepy ass cabin in the middle
of nowhere what's the big deal
there is a murderer on the loose and you
drove us into the woods
I forgot to bring vodka
you have seven and a half hours until
you're stuck here forever
before it happens
the machines kill us all no they more
just rip apart the fabric of our society
via dance videos on Tick Tock they just
dance against us
come on out water's warm just so you
know I don't do you pee out of
that thing
[Applause]
I think hey you did do
be alive
yeah let's not make that the lesson
[Music]
80s made sucks this is just dirt look at
all these Twigs if I could give you a
gummy this big it has 100 times more
weed than this
[Music]
[Applause]
it's Halloween
you know what that means
oh Sawtooth Jack is gonna rise from the
corn fields It's gotta be stopped kill
or be killed you've all heard the
stories
we failed at our duties and that black
dust destroyed our crops Our Lives it
must die
so we can live
your sacred Duty
is to take down Sawtooth Jack before
that church bell rings at midnight you
really think that's real
I saw it
it's real
you saw it
did you kill it
then let's go kill it
[Music]
you should do it you know I'm not
allowed just because your brother won
the run last year
I got an idea
if that thing isn't dead by midnight
this whole town is going straight to
hell
I want to go home I want to go home
you're special why are you doing this
if you're born in this town
I'm ending this
tonight
it ain't over
[Music]
stop the vehicle immediately
if they catch you they'll take you to a
laboratory get that through your head
what are you gonna do now stop the
vehicle immediately you don't have as
much control as you think you have
been looking for you for years what am I
doing here I want the formula in your
blood what formula the one that can
create or deactivate your powers
was that that's where the power is
to make others believe what you want
them to and remain invisible
we need to get out of here you know how
to fight
you have two options yes there's no time
you can keep going down this road you're
on which I guarantee will bring you
nothing but pain or you can come with me
dad forgive me
who was he
a perceiver
he can create projections like you as
well as many other things we believe
he's the last remaining member of the
awareness
What Makes You Different Makes You
Stronger
but into my mind
Wanna Know Who I Am we're a product in
there's more like you a mule is a myth
and thanks to the formula don't listen
to her we all suddenly develop certain
extra sensory abilities
I believe the word you're saying
[Music]
[Applause]
I miss you guys we don't even hang out
anymore we're barely ever together as a
group well that's how it goes maybe you
just got a little stuck After High
School I did not peak in high school
I have cancer what
kind of cancer do you have
[Music]
tonsil red pepper oh yes you know what
I think I have to go on this journey
alone
you don't have cancer did you read my
medical history I could have cancer I'm
sure do you want cancer
we're gonna be here by your side through
all of this friends to the end
not that you're gonna die soon
this cancer did the doctor say it was
from me we didn't know not to smoke when
we were pregnant it was a different time
I never should have taken
hallucinogenics though why are you lying
about having cancer my friends are
sleepwalking through their lives and
they were forgetting about me these
girls are my family they matter on a
level that blood never could yeah we
[Music]
core and a speedy healthy recovery
always made it if you're looking for
sympathy you're not gonna find it here
this is what it feels like to have
cancer Bottoms Up swallow
what why are you giving us the stank eye
we got cancer
[Music]
I don't have cancer you don't have to
lie to mask your fear I'm not lying
fitbank is textbook behavior let's go
you bunch of hot messes
[Music]
what's going on in there I'm coming in
no don't
[Music]
if you are bald we are bald
is she okay
she's drunk
the world's most famous explorer is back
like you've never seen her before
join Dora and all her friends
in the magical new short film
Dora and the Fantastical creatures
with Paw Patrol the mighty movie only in
theaters September 29th
guys honestly I don't know what I'm
gonna do work is a nightmare my boss
hates me and I'm close to exploding
I mean honestly it just sounds like you
really need to get laid
[Music]
what brings you and your gang up here
he's cooking at a food festival this is
[Music]
the dollhouse
it's what it says
at least we have shutters
the girls took me away for the weekend
did you ask
Mary you can't let him speak to you like
that he's really upset you know we have
plans this weekend like what sucking his
teeny pain and making him stink Boop
[Music]
this Festival is a pressure cooker
do you know what only reason we are here
is for you
you are so far up your career's ass that
you can't let anyone else in
struggle is normal
it's part of life
you have to show up for the people
around you and trust that they've got
your back every time I fall I get back
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
thank you